President Trump says a summit with North
Korean leader Kim jong-un will probably
take place in the next three or four
weeks possible locations for the meeting
include Singapore the Trump
administration's choice or Mongolia
which Kim could reach by train we Jiang
is at the White House where officials
are cautiously optimistic wage out good
morning Alex good morning the Trump
administration acknowledges North Korea
has recently kept its promise to stop
conducting more missile tests but
quickly adds it will not be naive when
and if negotiations begin given the
country's record of brokering than
breaking deals we're not going to take
words we're going to look for actions
and deeds the Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo said kim jeong-hoon must prove
he's willing to meet the
administration's demands does he want
the pressure campaign to continue or is
he looking for something big and bold
and different president Trump says he
won't accept less than full
denuclearization it's unclear how Kim
interprets that in exchange Kim want
sanctions relief and a promise the US
won't invade North Korea president Trump
is determined to see this opportunity
through on Face the Nation national
security advisor John Bolton wouldn't
say if the u.s. would make any promises
we want to see real commitment we don't
want to see propaganda from North Korea
I haven't seen such action action so far
we've seen words so dismantlement we've
seen word so far kim claims he will shut
down the country's nuclear test site in
May and open the door for the u.s. to
inspect activity but the regime has made
promises before in 2008 North Korea blew
up a cooling tower at its nuclear power
plant to show its commitment to stop
making nuclear weapons when diplomatic
talks fell apart the North conducted new
tests I think we'll have a meeting over
the next three or four weeks at a speech
in Michigan Saturday night president
Trump took credit for Friday's historic
summit between Kim and South Korean
president moon jae-in sang
what do you think President Trump had to
do with it
I'll tell you what like how about
everything we expect to hear from the
president later this afternoon he is
hosting the president of Nigeria here at
the White House and the two are
scheduled to hold a joint press
conference Norah
all right we just thank you